This video is sponsored by Wizards of
the Coast. Edge of Eternities is out,
bringing with it two new card types, two
new mechanics, one new ability word, and
two new tokens. So, here's your complete
rules breakdown covering the best cards,
the best strategies, and advanced rules
you need to know. Let's start with the
headliner mechanic, station. You can
find this mechanic on the two new card
types, spacecrafts and planets.
Spacecraft is a new artifact subtype and
planet is the new non-basic land
subtype. Station is a combination of
crew and enlist. As a sorcery, you can
tap a creature you control and then add
an amount of charge counters to the
permanent you are stationing equal to
the creature's power. Once the planet or
spacecraft has at least the amount of
counters, as noted by the numbers on the
left hand side of the card, the planet
or spacecraft will unlock those
abilities. Now, there are two new decks
that you need to be on the lookout for
using this new mechanic. The first is
the Kona Rescue Beasty Combo. This deck
looks to land the new card, the Serma, a
threecost spacecraft that when it
enters, you can search your library for
a legendary creature and put it into
your hand. You then follow that up with
a Coner, which you can also search for
with the Serma. Then you can use Coner
to station the spacecraft. This then
triggers Kona's ability, allowing you to
cheat in an omniscience or Galter to
then play out the rest of your hand.
Next is the Jesse artifacts deck that
looks to summon giant constructs with
similacrim synthesizer.
With these tokens, you can then fully
station new card Uros Titanic Godcore,
which then becomes the universally
banned Tallarian Academy, which can then
allow you to cast even more spells to
generate even more constructs and then
cheat in a fire crystal to give them all
haste and swing in for lethal. One last
thing, with the release of this set, any
legendary vehicle or legendary
spacecraft with a printed power and
toughness can now be your commander. So,
this opens up a whole heap of deck
building ideas, and you can pick up one
of these new legendary spacecrafts in
one of the two new Edge of Eternities
Commander decks. Or perhaps you might be
lucky enough to open one in a collector
booster. Click the link in the
description for more information. Next,
let's check out another powerful new
mechanic that is already shaking up the
metag game across multiple formats.
Warp. Personally, I would say warp is an
even more powerful variant of evoke.
Warp allows you to cast a permanent
spell for a discounted cost, and at the
end of the turn, that permanent gets
exiled, and you may cast it again for
its normal mana cost on a later turn.
There are two big things to note about
warped permanence. Firstly, warped
creatures. While in most cases they may
not be able to attack unless they have
haste, they can immediately station a
spacecraft or planet. Secondly, and this
is the big one, after you warp a card,
for example, Quantum Riddler, if at some
point during the turn you cast Splash
Portal on it, the creature will go to
exile and then come back, do its ETB
trigger, and becomes a new game object.
This is thanks to rule 400.7.
An object that moves from one zone to
another becomes a new object with no
memory of or relation to its previous
existence.
This means that the creature will not
exile itself at the end of turn. We're
also seeing warp show up in the new
standard Sepharoth deck. Timeline Color
is fast becoming a cornerstone card of
the deck. Alongside the other new Edge
of Eternity's card, Umbreal Collar
Zealot. With these two cards in play and
a couple of Ventrol Blood Witches, you
can drain your opponent for as much life
as you have black mana available. Just
simply sacrifice the color to the
Zealot. The blood witches or Sephro will
trigger, dealing damage to your opponent
and gaining you life. And then you can
warp the timeline color from your
graveyard and repeat the loop. And even
if the board gets wiped, you can bring
everything back with a single cast of
Raise the Past. In this same Sephro
sacrifice deck, we also get to see the
new ability word in action, void. Void
simply checks to see if a non-land
permanent has left the battlefield or if
a spell was warped this turn. And if
something has, it gets a bonus effect.
as seen on tragic trajectory, a clear
call back to tragic slip, a one- mana
sorcery that gives a creature minus 2
minus two. But if void has been engaged,
the creature gets - 10 - 10. Having
something leave the battlefield is easy
enough in the Sephro deck. One big thing
to note with void is that it only
activates off of non-land permanence. So
cracking fetchlands won't turn this
ability online. Now, it's worth talking
about the two new tokens that dropped
with this set as well, as both are
making a splash in standard. First, we
have lander tokens, an artifact where
you can pay two, tap, and sacrifice it
to search your library for a basic land
and put it into play tapped. In
standard, you'll see these tokens most
commonly being generated from the one
mana sorcery Sammi's Curiosity as this
is a nice setup piece for the monogreen
landfall deck that has been rising in
popularity.
There's also biotech specialist, a two
mana 1 three that creates a lander when
it enters, but it also has the ability
whenever you sacrifice an artifact, this
creature deals two damage to target
opponent. So, this not only triggers
with lander tokens being sacrificed, it
also goes great with the next new token,
munitions. You can generate munition
tokens through the new card, weapons
manufacturing, a two mana red
enchantment that says, "Whenever a
non-token artifact you control enters,
create a colorless artifact token named
munitions with, when this token leaves
the battlefield, it deals two damage to
any target." So when combined with
biotech specialist, that's four damage
each time a munition leaves the
battlefield. So you can combine these
cards with either Umbreal Collar Zealot
or Embrace Oblivion or even Rotten Mouth
Viper for maximum value. It's worth
reminding you that these tokens say when
this token leaves the battlefield. So,
if your opponent tries to remove all of
the tokens with something like Pinnacle
Star Cage, the tokens will still trigger
even if they get exiled.
Now, if you want to check out any of the
decks I've mentioned in this video, I'll
link them in the description down below.
As for my favorite cards of the set,
Sunset Sabotur is already putting in
work in my standard Monoblack mid-range
deck alongside Archene Enemies Charm and
Ice Till Explorer is definitely going in
my Necroloom Commander deck. Let me know
what cards you're looking forward to.
And as always, be sure to like the video
if you learned something. Thanks again
to Wizards of the Coast for sponsoring
this video. Edge of Eternities is
available everywhere now. And make sure
you head to your LGS to experience
Magic's space fantasy set. And subscribe
because if you don't, I'll take you to
the next eternity.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one.